having started software businesses
before my biggest piece of advice here
is that you need to have a software
co-founder you need somebody who's a
technical co-founder who will work day
and night someone who loves code loves
making products that people love if you
don't have that person and it's like a
third party shop or you're paying I can
count on like one hand the amount of
companies that have succeeded that way
versus having a technical co-founder if
you're trying to do this on the side and
the likelihood that you really get to
something that's massive is really low
the guys you're competing against
because there are guys who are probably
looking at the same industry building a
product right now that does the same
thing they're well capitalized and
they're Savages they don't have a side
hustle it's their main Hustle